I would actually like us to draw the
section of the graph of the function we
were looking at yesterday what was what
was the function journalist Thanks we
would try to find we're trying to
evaluate the square root really
and the expression the equation that we
introduced was X minus 3 because 3 3 is
a solution to this sum a root reason for
Java to this function so if you're on
today I'm the part of the graph that
will fit onto here remembering that I
think replaced 1 & 2 around here and you
have to know in advance where root 3
actually is so you're going to get
something like this so this is a big
mistake
some teams really follow ok I know I
have a stationary point on the y axis so
that's why it's so flat
ok yeah remember what we're trying to do
we are trying to find an approximation
for this value I mean I know what it
actually is exactly root 3 but then that
begs the question well what's root 3 and
we've got an approximation yesterday but
you may recall I made a point to say the
myth that we used which is called one of
those who names again either by section
or having the interval right um it was
very simplistic I mean that was the
beauty of it it's like you don't you
very much math to be able to do this you
just need to know the difference is
really negative and positive and you
need to be over half things that's not
difficult ok but for that reason because
it's so simple
it was quite slow we had to go many many
steps before we fought any work and with
other functions sometimes it's even
slower so Newton method in thought look
I've got tools
I've got tools more sophisticated than
just knowing the different with plus and
minus
right um I I happen to be one of the
co-inventors on this thing calculus so
how can I use that to help me okay let
me show you when he uh waiting you
looked at this you said you remember how
we evaluated a couple of spots right we
evaluated it at 1 & 2 okay and then we
actually got some values for okay now
for reasons that will become clear I
mean I'm just gonna take one is whatever
here this all become more important to
us do you remember what happened when we
put two in what value did I get I got
what might because 2 squared minus 3 is
1 so I'm gonna value up here and that's
2 comma 1 that's the key win now what
does calculus do what is like the
student power of calculus what is it
what are we used for the beginner a big
differentiator
it's that slope exact gradient in fact
that's why we define first principles it
is just rise over run in the living case
of one being zero okay or a frequency so
if I think about this point and I think
about the tangent at that point the
tangent at that point is going to be
extraordinarily useful to me in trying
to solve this problem of where's the
root can you see why let's just quickly
put on the tangent at that point do your
best
I actually brought my ruler office
now you have a look at this stage
because of the nature of a tangent right
the tendrá is a very good approximation
to occur at a particular point this
tangent is kind of hugging two wards
have brother
you can see how person is yeah so
therefore this tangent is going to
intercept things it's going to intersect
with the axis really really close to the
root notice that right like remember how
I was doing before I said okay how about
halfway and then all I knew was I okay
will be somewhere in here look at how I
just go from one point if I can find out
where that is right where my tangent
intersects with the axis I'm gonna be
super close and then if I do it again
this is gonna be hard to fit onto your
diagram but try this is why I asked you
to draw it so be if I do this again and
say take this is my value and say okay
in the same way that I went up like this
what if I went up again like that and
then I drew the tangent again on my
graph which I think will the gradient is
quite much okay I can almost not
distinguish the tangent from the actual
curve itself that's the whole point of
attention you know this this makes sense
right a tangent is an approximation of
the curve at a point so therefore if
you're trying to approximate the root
the tangent is a very very useful tool
for us okay so you can see just by going
two steps right
I'm just I'm almost sitting on top of it
okay in fact can you get the value in a
second so just reading this time this
bad back off how am I going to find that
point how am I actually going to locate
miss Manning what kind of geometry can I
take advantage of okay so I need an x
intercept for this tangent Wow I guess I
would generally need the equation of
that tangent to do so okay now I can do
that by the way I'm just going to come
out and say that's one of the ways that
I can do this however there's an even
simpler
I don't even need to work out the
equation of this tangent have a look at
this right this here owns a triangle
right what kind of triangle does it for
it's running okay look if not right this
is a right angle triangle I know a lot
of how by degra try me
I have a whole bunch of information
about this okay so for instance right
just for the sake of notation okay I'm
going to call this point X know like I
actually know its value but I call it X
more to signify this is the first x
value that I'm starting with okay so
it's an X value and it's more because
that's the beginning if that X naught
what is being height of this triangle
it's f of X naught and this is by
particular so this distance here is f or
not agreed okay now remember how I drew
an extra line here now I got rid of it
the whole idea is that we're going to do
this a successive number of times so I'm
going to go to X naught then the next
one that I gave a retreat closer will be
X well I'm and then if I wanna get
closer to next so this point is quite a
dissection I'm gonna call it x1 all
right I know the height of the triangle
what is the width of the base it's just
gonna be the difference between these
two do you agree with them so this
length here is X naught takeaway X 1 now
in this right angle triangle what pieces
of knowledge what function relates the
height to the nice and Sun Tan right
it's turn of this angle tan of that a so
I'm just gonna write down first then tan
oh and I'm just calling a theta for now
tan of theta is opposite on adjacent
okay now this point you might think why
didn't we just go through the creation
of the tape it wouldn't have been that
hard okay why didn't I just evaluate
that and then you know sub in y equals
zero okay well look at this right what
would be the easiest way to find out
what ten feet it is and yeah and the
answer is I look this comes from the
gradient at a particular point right tan
theta that's where it comes from
in fact like by definition rise over run
this time he R is the gradient at that
point do you agree with that the grain
at that point is tan theta M equals 10
p.m. right so this is in fact f - f -
where because it's not just f - a
function it's a particular f that
external it's F - at the point where the
tangent is right does that make sense
that's explora okay so here I thought
now all the pieces I need without even
knowing what the equation is what is it
trying to find again like I know about X
mornings that's where I started I was
after x1 so all I need to do is a tiny
bit of rearrangement here let me swap
these two guys around right so that's
gonna become that and that puts these
knives over here on the right hand side
in a very nice piece of symmetry right
and then what I want is X 1 so again I
just a to you one little switch I'm up
to me like this
look mom no crazy okay isn't that
beautiful
right just taking advantage of these
triangles and I am going to
differentiate but that's okay I'm really
good at differentiating given some
starting point like say X naught equals
2 I can get to a point that's gonna be
really close if I want to get close up
if that's not actually enough away I'll
just do it again let's see what happens
because we did this process yesterday
right what is f dash X goes to X okay so
if I say let X naught let the first
approximation let it be true that's
where we started last time I get one
more X 1 X 1 is going to be X naught
takeaway right so what was a fault
excellent we already went that one move
up okay F dash X naught of X naught
that's 1 and 3/4 right now immediately
I'm already twice as fast as the
bisection method it took me two steps to
get to there I have to get to one and
I'm off first and then I got to one of
three quarters because I knew it wasn't
gonna be on that side okay but I'm
already there let's see when X 2 gives
us what we do next - it's gonna be X 1
take away f of X 1 what is infinite
you've actually probably
29 and 685 which means which is yes
wait yeah what a 16 that is what I want
that's right it's 48 and 16 is 3 that's
f of x1 on F dash of X 1 I just
multiplied by 2 - can someone tell me
what again
can someone give me a dozen you just
worked out this pot well your sentence
which 1.73 to okay just almost for a
minute right look at how much work we
have done and how close we already are
okay just for the sake of it okay you
want to take this number you want to
store it into your calculator right like
I didn't just gifts to one cuz you don't
want to type that thing all over again
right and then just one more time just
to see how close we're going to get I'm
going to take that one point seven three
two data does not - f all 1.73 - so all
you have to do is like if you call that
a when you calculate up you're just
going to go a squared minus three and
then you do these two times you know try
to store
whatever give me a decimal 1.7 okay can
someone tell me what root 3 is only two
three seven three five sir okay someone
you can want decimal place on this I
wouldn't a company name is it the same
how many decimal places accuracy is that
oh snap
all right the bisection method is not
it's so simple it's like someone can
very easily crunch through that but then
you look at this guy and he just leaves
the bisection method in the dust
admittedly we took advantage of some
much bigger machinery we used the
derivative of course that's going to be
more exact of course it's going to be
faster
assuming you can differentiate okay but
boy that's impressive